pourquoi encore aggraver la division de
la gauche ah ben d'abord ce sera pas du
tout une division puisque c'est la seule
liste hor nupess je note que la
balcanisation de la gauche c'est dans la
nupess c'est leur affaire hors nupess je
ne connais à ce stade qu'une seule liste
celle que nous nous proposons de
présenter ensuite je sais bien que les
procès en division viennent toujours
mais je préfère les procès en division
que les procès en compromission il se
trouve que ma famille politique depuis
l'origine n'a pas souhaité aller dans
laanupes parce qu'elle ne souhaitait pas
se soumettre au projet politique des
insoumis et encore moins à l'infamie
d'un certain nombre de leurs
responsables depuis les dernières
semaines qui est-ce qui pourrait
composer cette liste aux élections
européennes nous avons dit d'entrer de
jeu que le sujet aujourd'hui c'était
effectivement au moment où notre pays
connaît des tensions inouï au moment où
la violence s'exprime partout au moment
où la violence s'exprime autour de nous
nous sommes dans un contexte
international extrêmement inquiétant au
moment où les défis aussi auquels nous
sommes confrontés je pense au
réchauffement climatique je pense au
défis ycpris prix économique dans ce
moment-là on peut pas vraiment se
permettre de vouloir jouer la bannière
d'abord il faut d'abord jouer le
rassemblement l'ouverture la capacité
surtout à apporter des réponses
cohérentes aux peur aux colères et donc
nous allons ouvrir notre listre à toutes
celles et ceux qui sont orphelins de
cette gauche républicaine laïque
pro-européenne toutes celles et ceux qui
étaient déçus du macronisme jusqu'à
gluxman jusque aux écologistes de jade
veulent faire une liste cohérente
politiquement pour répondre au problèm
des Français le nom de Bernard cassduv
circule beaucoup il pourrait accompagner
cette liste Bernard casenu a créé la
convention dans laquelle nous l'avons
rejoint pour faire le rassemblement
Bernard casenu est un homme qui prône le
rassemblement de la gauche cohérente
depuis des mois et des mois donc berar
casu reste sur cette ligne politique qui
est la sienne par ailleurs la convention
n'est pas un parti politique oui mais
pour ces élections européennes cas est
un homme d'État je ne pense pas que son
rôle soit aujourd'hui d'être vraiment
impliqué dans ce moment de construction
des listes politique il dira ce qu'il a
à dire il a commencé à le dire chez nous
samedi en disant qu'il prenait le
rassemblement il dira dans les semaines
qui viennent comment il voit évoluer la
situation c'est sa parole n'a jamais été
question qu'il en soit la tête non
est-ce qu'il vous a dit qu'il allait
s'engager dans la campagne à vos côtés
il a dit que il s'engagerait pour le
rassemblement charge maintenant à celles
et ceux à gauche et donc au premier r
desquel le Parti radical de gauche qui
est quand même le seul parti qui propose
le rassemblement moi je ne note que des
partis qui proposent d'être entre eux
enfermés dans leurs officines qui ont
toutes échoué alors que nous sommes les
seuls à dire que finalement au regarde
la situation le sujet c'est pas
tellement le drapeau du parti le sujet
c'est véritablement la patrie vous dites
que vous êtes la seule liste hornupè le
Parti socialiste a suspendu a décidé
d'un moratoire de sa participation à
cette union de la gauche de la nuupess
autour de la France insoumise pourquoi
ne pas faire une liste commune avec les
socialistes et parce que moi je ne crois
pas que la politique ce soit des
moratoire quand vous êtes confronté à
l'infamie de ce qui a été dit par un
grand nombre de parlementaires et les
filles suite aux événements dramatiques
et tragique qui est horrible du 7
octobre quand vous êtes dans une dans un
moment politique où il faut montrer une
fermeté républicaine à toute épreuve et
en même temps évidemment une
bienveillance humaniste de gauche pour
aussi accompagner les peurs et les
colères et bien dans ce moment-là vous
ne vous posez pas la question de savoir
si LFI est fréquentable ou ne l' pas LFI
a un projet politique qui ne correspond
en rien à ce qui est une gauche de
gouvernement ils ont un projet politique
ils ont des méthodes politiques aussi et
ces méthodes sont insupportables à la
majorité du temps partir de là vous ne
vous posez pas la question de savoir si
vous allez attendre voir si ça rrange si
ça améliore et cetera c'est bon chacun a
vu depuis maintenant 2 ans ce qui les
fit Guillaume Lacroix vous pourriez
travailler avec quelqu'un d'autre que
Jean Mélenchon à la tête je ne veux pas
faire du sujet le sujet Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est trop facile je ne peux
pas travailler avec madame auonau je ne
peux pas travailler avec Monsieur guirud
je ne peux pas travailler avec un projet
politique qui n'est pas clairement
républicain je ne peux pas travailler
avec un projet politique qui n'est pas
clairement fondé sur j'allais dire une
forme d'expression publique qui soit
respectueuse qui ne soit pas en
permanence en train de chercher et de
provoquer la violence si jamais les
socialistes décident de sortir de la nup
vous leur tendez la main pour les
élections européennes évidemment j'ai
été de tous les combats avec les
socialistes pendant des années donc
c'est pas à moi qu'on va faire le procès
de l'hostilité par principe au Parti
socialiste simplement je le dis moi en
2019 je faisais la campagne de rap
gluxman au côté du Parti socialiste
depuis c'est pas moi qui a changé depuis
c'est eux c'est eux qui ont fait
d'autres choix politiques je leur laisse
faire je les respecte mais je ne les
partage pas face à la situation
politique on ne reste pas dans
l'hypocrisie la laacheté d'un moratoire
on sait où on habite et on le dit aux
Français et aux Français vous savez dans
ce moment-là où les gens ne croient plus
dans nos partis politiques dans ce
moment-là où les gens croient plus
vraiment la parole politique il ne reste
qu'une chose la clarté de la sincérité
donc soit vous êtes sincère et clair et
nous nous sommes cohérents au PRG depuis
des années en disant nous n'irons pas
nous soumettre au projet insoumis parce
que ça n'est pas le nôtre il est
contraire à notre histoire il est
contraire à notre philosophie politique
on est pour l'union de la gauche mais
moi je préfère la gauche plurielle à la
nupess les choses sont claires je
préfère l'équilibre des forces de gauche
à la domination par son extrême et un
des extrêmes qui est aujourd'hui dans
des postures qui sont inqualifiables et
pourquoi le PRG qui représente ce centre
gauche ne ferait pas liste commune
notamment avec la majorité
présidentielle la liste de la majorité
présidentielle qui va rassembler des
proeuropéens ce sont les mots ce weekend
de Stéphane séjourné qui est pressenti
pour diriger cette liste ben parce que
dans Partir ave de gauche il dit à
gauche et donc pour vous il a il y a
plus de gauche au sein de la majorité
présidentielle je ne l'entends plus vous
l'entendez plus ben justement on va
parler de l'avenir de la gauche toujours
sur le Parti socialiste est-ce que selon
vous ce parti socialiste a encore un
avenir alors que par exemple Bernard
casenu pense qu'Olivier fort sera je le
cite le dernier Premier secrétaire de ce
parti c'est moi je ne suis pas
socialiste je n'ai jamais été je rentré
au Parti radical de gauche à 18 ans
militant de base je suis devenu
président de ce parti je suis fier
d'appartenir à un parti qui permet cette
logique de mérite républicain qui permet
cette logique finalement de construction
autour des convictions ce qui se passe
au Parti socialiste les regardent c'est
leur histoire c'est leur vie ce sont vos
alliés historiques ce sont des alliés
historiques mais je le dis aussi dans ce
moment-là au moment où l'histoire
politique s'écrit chacun prend ses
responsabilités le PRG prend les siennes
il ditous il faut une offre politique
cohérente républicaine laïque
pro-européenne il faut la faire avec
toutes celles et tous ceux qui partagent
ce point de vue je pense à Carole Delga
de la fusse je pense évidemment à à
Nicola ma aussi il y a plein de
socialistes avec lesquels je travaille
et puis il y en a qui ne travaillent
plus avec nous et dans ce cadre là il y
a le premier secrétaire qui ne veut plus
travailler avec moi qui ne me donne
aucun signe de vie qui a décidé que
globalement son sujet c'était pas de
travailler avec ce camp là mais c'est
son droit c'est son choix mais moi j'ai
pris mes responsabil raison d'ailleurs
quelle raison vous donne je ne cherche
pas je ne suis Passi globalement chacun
prend ses responsabilités donc
finalement vous ne croyez plus dans
cette union de la gauche large vous
parler de de gauche pluriel enfin vous
pensez qu' il va y avoir de
gauchesréconcili quand je vous parle de
gauche pluriel moi je crois que que
justement je crois en l'union de la
gauche je ne crois pas à la soumission à
la France insoumise je crois au fait que
la gauche a toujours été dans ce pays
construite par des partis avec des
sensibilités différentes on a besoin de
l'écologie des écologistes on a besoin
du discours social du Parti communiste
on a besoin du discours républicain
laïque du PRG et on a aussi besoin d'un
socialisme qui soit à nouveau un
socialisme de gouvernement qui ne
tergiverse pas entre des méthodes
inqualifiable de etfi et un projet
politique honnêtement auquel nous devons
opposer une autre réponse politique
[Musique]